how much of the Suburban female vote
though is just social pressures I mean I
think I think there's a ton of it but I
think that moms are more likely
to kind of I mean we saw it with Junkin
you can't mess with the mama bears these
are women who probably in the past well
I'm sure they hated Trump I'm sure a lot
of women a lot of women did not want to
vote for Trump uh it's the way that he
talked about women the comments but you
know the youngest stuff that to me
proves that you can't really mess with
the Suburban moms you can't do the
social justice stuff with their kids you
just can't do it you're not going to win
what was I I imagine what was the or I
should I wonder what you think the
Catalyst was for the Suburban moms to
wake up to the problem and then vote in
a Republican
I think that uh part of it was the
horrendous rape case and the whole
school board was basically in on
silencing it I mean that's somebody's
daughter that's interesting and they
chose they chose to to cover that up and
to try to downplay it but this is
interesting it's it's you know Donald
Trump says things women don't like yeah
they don't like the way he behaves and
so they vote against him then you get
the story in in Virginia where a female
is assaulted and mothers quickly respond
I wonder if it's just female Centric
right something they're seeing affecting
them specifically that's causing the
direct response I mean maybe I I I I
think the other big part of it though is
is is the the
SE teachers and these these super woke
people in our children's lives now too I
think that there's a driving divide to
just
I mean to divide our kids from us and I
think that's very scary are they gonna
vote for DeSantis
I mean I I can understand not liking
Trump right but what about this answer
well I think that how do you I mean I
don't know I for for me personally I
mean I I I could see a DeSantis vote
easily happening and I think it is
interesting to watch the left try to
demonize DeSantis as they are you you
can't you Trump can't be the Antichrist
and then DeSantis is the Antichrist now
and he's actually worse than Trump and
you can't just keep doing this forever
and ever and ever I got it though oh boy
I got it I got it correct me if I'm
wrong but if the scientist gets super
ripped and then does that yoga handstand
thing on his desk that like Trudeau did
I think he'll get all the links but but
but what if he also figures out newsom's
hairspray yeah yes the hair gel I want
to see them debate they were talking
about yes on Twitter they were chatting
back and forth or something about you
baby it was about their hair though yeah
let's start there let's start with our
hair products and then get personal and
then talk about politics it was a debate
about hair so so they were talking about
products yes right so gel versus spread
they want to get reelected that's oh
that's pretty funny but I I like Newsome
apparently wants to like shoehorn his
way in on Biden if Biden doesn't oh yeah
and now Biden's actually doubting he was
asked if he was going to run he's like
well it's a little too soon it's like
you were just saying all the time you're
gonna do it but Newsome is like he looks
like a snake oil salesman this is a
military guy yeah you know I mean he was
Jag but you know I I genuinely do think
um not to be as as crass as the joke
about a hunky DeSantis because Trudeau
women seem to like but I do think that
DeSantis is substantially more appealing
for a variety of reasons he's younger he
is just let's just say it any any uh
anyone can acknowledge he is more
attractive than Donald Trump himself
yeah of course
oh you're you think you think Trump is
I don't think DeSantis is all that easy
on the eyes I think that if you put him
in Newsome I mean I think Newsom yes
snake oil salesman greasy Kendall sure
sure but isn't he like really tall yeah
yeah yeah Sanders is like what five
times that could be a that could be a
Kennedy Nixon TV yeah waiting to happen
yeah who gets sweatier yeah that's why
Nixon lost that debate we know we know
that Newsome doesn't get sweatier
because he wears fleece and 80 degrees
105 degree weather so he's sweatproof
well at least you know look who if you
put Donald Trump next to Ronda Sanders
who the lady is going to pick
I mean Trump well after January 6
they're going to pick the Santas I just
think that DeSantis you you eliminate a
lot of the baggage drama that women
didn't like yeah and so you bring out a
guy who's like I'm gonna protect your
kids I'm gonna do right by you he's
younger it's more relatable and I think
I think desantises would would get a lot
more Suburban women I I think so too I
think that the way you know like the the
Stormy Daniels stuff the grab the pee
stuff like all all those remarks were
were nasty also I went back at one point
and started trying to find the old
episodes of the um of The Apprentice and
they're all pretty much wipe now they're
all pretty much gone but the cup the
when I did start this little venture or
whatever the episode the beginning
episodes the way he treated women was
crazy and this was years ago years ago
but you know I mean I like Trump at
first but yeah I mean I can see how how
regular women could be really very much
off put by the way he was I think it's
emotional and social for a lot of for a
lot of women I think women are more
susceptible to social pressures than men
yeah absolutely it's not I I don't know
how substantial it is but it's just more
we see it with Instagram we see it with
Tick Tock women are doing young girls
are doing these Tick Tock things with a
fake terminal illnesses they're getting
Tourette ticks from watching other
people yeah substantially more than
young men yeah and so when when the
media keeps screaming over and over
again that Trump is nasty and gross and
evil you end up with a lot of uh namely
Millennial women who are just like yes
then you end up with a lot of male
feminists weaker men who are like
anything you say baby because I'm trying
to sleep with you and then you end up
with people voting and developing this
Mass formation psychosis instead of just
being like I am a being unto myself with
my own thoughts and opinions and while I
do find Trump to be sometimes gross his
posse decisions actually are a lot
better than Joe Biden's so I'll vote for
that instead
well that's why those men on the street
videos that that I think you've had a
couple guys on who do those videos
they're so important because it just
shows that these people have no idea
about policy at all they're totally just
going with the grain yep they have no
idea and their emotions people are
emotionally manipulated I was going to
suggest we play Mary kill uh bone but
that's not a family friendly there's a
game
um
yeah but family-friendly show there so I
don't think it's I don't think it's that
appropriate but on the members only show
we'll do it when the kids are in bed
that's great let's get them
Nancy Pelosi the wood shop worker and uh
and uh Hillary Clinton Losi all the way
man I'm asking you guys that [ __ ]
I didn't say on the show she's solving
the formula crisis single-handedly oh
yeah no absolutely when Alex Stein was
on the show he made an interesting
um point that the war in the Middle East
has just kind of evolved into the war in
Ukraine I hadn't thought of it that way
yes absolutely it was so blatant did
another one started you know he also and
and it's funny because you it's like
like clockwork but he also ate that chip
and the one chip challenge you know he
actually approached Dan Crenshaw on the
street I didn't have a chance to talk to
him I was on the show with him but I
thought he was saying like you guys
served a bad War you're bad I don't know
if he but he was insulting him
personally I think well his height and
stuff like that he said you sacrificed
you know I think he said something like
I could be wrong look at you you know
you lost your eye fighting a war on
unjust war or something yeah and what
the thing is if he had been alive and an
adult when in 2001 when that Towers came
down pretty much everybody believed but
how old was he how old is he he's not
he's 36 yeah so he's so he was like 14.
he was young he wasn't an adult but like
when you when you were an adult at that
time you everyone pretty much thought we
got attacked by terrorists so it was
like they weren't bad people for
fighting in that war it wasn't until
later like in 2008 and seven that we
started to realize that we'd been snowed
so I hope that Dan Crenshaw and Alex
Stein have a chance to talk again well I
think the issue is Dan Crenshaw is
I don't he's he's what's the right word
for you know he started when Crenshaw
started off people were very much
interested in in who he was and then he
started to become more and more swampy
you know swampy and War hawkish and
stuff like that
yeah I don't know him personally I was
listening to Rogan one time and I was
like who is he canceled on us twice yeah
I was listening to an interview on Rogan
I was like who is that annoying guy and
then I looked over and it was it was Dan
Crenshaw I'm like oh my God why he was
like pandering to Joe and like but I
mean I listened the show got better as
it went on but I was kind of rubbed the
wrong way at first here's what I don't
know him I'd like to know him though
here's what I don't like Alex Stein he
called Crenshaw eye patch McCain he said
really nasty
yeah I don't like that what I do like is
when Alex was actually commenting AOC as
as a sort of activist troll kind of
thing I like I I think that one's a
little crude but he ultimately got a
major story out of that when he was
confronted by protesters and he said I
love you all and wish you all the best
that is amazing and I think that's
that's the brilliant kind of trolling of
laughing and smiling that he does well
like Luke you never you approached a lot
of guys on the street in like Dan
crenshaw's position Larry Silverstein um
I mean the list goes on Rothschild's big
neighborhood
Tony Blair Bill Clinton Hillary Clinton
Island I never saw you insult there
there at home and I never saw you
comment on their ugliness or their
height or any of that you were just like
hear the facts comment and that was the
way I think that's the way you do it
well you know I was a little facetious
sometimes when you know Kissinger was
having his uh private dinner being
awarded the freedom award I asked him
how does it feel being a mass murderer
receiving an award for Freedom when you
were murdered and butchered so many
people around the world with your
horrible policies especially in Cambodia
and Afghanistan and Chile in the Middle
East I could keep going on and on and on
uh but but predominantly that was like
the sixth time I talked to him but the
first initial ones was always hey you
talked about how military men are dumb
stupid animals please explain this is
according to Bob Woodward who said this
on record that that you publicly made
this statement how do you respond and he
said you know he called me a bunch of
names he actually resorted to make you
know trying to make fun of me and and
trying to call me a horrible human being
a me a monster and me a warm terminal
which was kind of hilarious and funny
but uh you know everyone has their
different approaches Alex says his I had
mine
um but they made it almost virtually
impossible to get to a lot of these
people but you know that's beyond the
point here and uh it's not easy you're
in the moment people get emotional
there's a lot of different energy going
around and it's very hard to kind of be
concise and control yourself and it's
it's a fine art being able to like talk
to a lot of these people I really like
Alex I I will say this I like Alex Stein
I I think that he's he's very smart I
think he does what he does very well but
I do think he screws up because I think
that it's kind of like when Tucker
Carlson is calling Lori Lightfoot
Beetlejuice it's like it's so
distracting and you know when when
they're winning an argument then they do
that stuff and everyone's like oh it's
like you'd have to do this again it's
like on one hand I get it you know it
makes it more fun to watch it is it's
entertaining it's relatable I'm sure it
really you know gets the clicks and
everything up but at the same time it's
like you're just taking away from the
actual
like you're winning without this you
don't need to do this it's like when he
did the big booty latina thing it was
like why are you doing that like it was
just it was gross and I mean the
challenge is
afterwards AOC came out and claimed that
January 6 may have been an inside job
had Alex not done what he did we
wouldn't have had her coming out and
calling for an active investigation and
I was like that's a really good outcome
yeah an AOC fans don't justify the means
man I mean AOC also you know insults a
lot of people she also said we have to
make politicians uncomfortable yeah and
she called on for a lot of these
policies which you know she's getting
affected on so again there's a debate to
be had here what's the right approach I
don't know well it's not calling Rosie
O'Donnell a fat pig I mean if you want
to lose the will of the American people
that's what Donald Trump did and I don't
want to see Alex go down that path yeah
yeah so that that's why you know going
back to the DeSantis stuff and yeah the
women vote right I think how you turn
them off right there so do you think it
was the women vote in the last election
that cost Donald Trump the election from
your work in PR uh uh do you no I think
it was the pandemic okay yeah I think I
think he would have won without the
pandemic I think he handed the
presidency over to fauci and I think
that yeah he lost the country he
absolutely did and then he tried to get
Bill Gates as His science advisor and he
took advice from Bill Gates and he
implemented the policies that Bill Gates
wanted admittedly Bill Gates is talking
about this right now bragging about it
so he lost a lot of people especially
with his administration starting the 14
days to slow the spread which was just a
horrible horrible approach I just don't
I I have to say though I don't like that
he gets blamed for the such poor
handling of the pandemic because I don't
think anybody knew what to do and and it
was so everybody's favorite word it must
have been probably the the top used word
was unprecedented and unprecedented it
was and Trump thought well I'm taking
the advice from you know Dr fauci I'm
taking advice from from all of these
experts you know and all of these you
know science people and everything and
he did listen to them at first I don't
think he got enough credit for listening
to them at first I think that's also
what cost him everything
um but the left will say that he ignored
scientists and didn't take anyone's
advice and it's just you know whichever
side you ask they can
spew what he did wrong and it was a mess
and it was unfair and then of course
January 6 happened and that's it I think
that's a nail in his coffin so you think
2024 Trump's not gonna be able to pull
it off because of those things or what I
don't think that he's going to be able
to pull it off because of January 6. I I
think that any chance that he would have
had to try to come back I think he he's
he squandered it DeSantis though you
think he'll win I think that he could
win I don't I mean I don't know who the
Democrats would want who would run who
could beat him yeah I know what do you
think Gavin Newsom I think Trump is
beautiful do you think Gavin Newsom
could beat DeSantis yeah Whitmore is
going to run this is going to run whip
I I think I think that if you I I feel
like Newsom though should be defeated
while Michael schellenberger could I
think dismantle him
um but you take one video of
San Francisco I mean how how can I mean
but I guess we talk about media ignoring
important things I mean out outside the
front door of every major you know News
network is a huge homeless crisis
because it's a liberal run City and yeah
so I mean
he has a slick look and Voodoo judge
also has the CIA connections that could
also bring them forward thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there